hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Yves now we're still
exploring this area just a little bit
and it's my friends and that lady has
the biggest boner or not lady with her
umbrella oh sure it is
to cover it up okay anyway so these
mannequin heads are here again I wonder
if it has a body let's take it off the
table for my break take it off
yes I'm sure ow yeah whatever
it didn't hurt me I'm gonna smash it all
smash them all take it off
oh I was good no no no no no no no these
mannequin heads need to die oh wow oh
wow okay what was the point of that I
really didn't need to do any of that did
I I I'm so sorry I apologize sincerely I
didn't mean to kill your friends I uh I
shouldn't have done that
Bastien with that I shouldn't have done
- put finger in my fingers too small
he's tricky alright okay hey what is
this place there's no color
let's meet rainbow on the canvas
floating palette and brush someone there
does that mean giant chasm
what does this mean there's a key over
there that I can't get to just yet but
uh we'll heal up hey there's someone
here now hey Fisher man he's got the
fishhook over on the other side that
means oh oh I know
that means Gary can give me something
through the fishhook and then I'll be
able to go ooh this is getting
interesting no no no no no no no no no
not there not there not there okay
fishing hook coming out of the painting
touch it
ow got my finger well that was stupid
wasn't it don't touch it
all right so I need to find something oh
the tree key of course all right all
right all right now checking our books
what Zarate enlightenment enlightenment
okay can't move that one can't move that
one theories of the world via training
of existences the imaginary can be made
a reality not sure what that means
okay conquer the unknown in know no fear
oh okay I guess I was at that terror
being alone is fearful a group of two
can have relief a group of three the
rest of you torn off I hope even Mary
are okay well as long as there are two
of them I guess this Gary guy I like him
the essentials of color ah it describes
the uses of color oh there we go
tame ball of paint green ball of paint
vanished alrighty then
well I need to get over there but it's
not letting me maybe this like a secret
passage or some
no apparently not maybe the back of this
some no no no no no no no no I'm trying
to think outside the box here but
apparently that's not gonna happen uh oh
well I got the pedestals and paint
getting pretty good here I guess oh I
get it
oh I get it the seven balls of paint the
room will be colored in the bridge will
be made they're talking about the black
and white room I need to find more paint
that's what I need to find but how am I
gonna find more paint I can bear oh
hello
well there we go I guess that's good but
how do I uh do I continue oh hey you're
new what are you doing I want to play
too
finding oops sorry I didn't mean to save
over that one whoops my bad
I'm uh trying to find some paint and
hopefully I'm gonna be able to find some
don't know what I'm doing do not know
what I am doing I need to find something
to give I need to give eat the stuff but
I can't go in here cuz that's bad
there's a paint ball in there I know
that hey I think I'm tapped down aren't
I
maybe there's something I could go back
I don't know if there'd be a point of me
I don't think so now that was this a
long hallway with no reward I'm gonna
keep moving forward in Canada it's gotta
be something there's got to be something
oh that's not a good thing I wouldn't
survive that Trek would I definitely not
definitely not okay all right I need to
I need to ah what do I do
very confused very confused it's Clarke
cracks in the floor weird gas coming out
what does that mean
wait did I actually do something good
wait a minute that means the gas is
gonna vent out of that one into here
right right maybe I don't know baby I
don't know not exactly sure I'm trying
to figure this out but I'm at a bit of a
loss here I don't know
what do i do what do I do about that
this is still blocked up and I need to
get something to do the pallet cuz
Gary's on the other side filling it up
but I don't know what I need to do and
that's still locked it's gotta be
something that I do with this fisherman
there's gotta be I send something across
I know I do I just don't know what oh
these are the parts that I hate being
stuck oh oh oh the juggler oh oh is it
six to three 500 okay then it's it's not
the lady in red ergo it must be the last
one oh six to three three six two to
three yeah there we go alright wait a
minute this is one more thing oh come on
but that's that's hardly any better it's
hardly any better but I mean what did
that do for me I still need three more
pain
gosh dang it haha that helped a little
bit but not a lot what else am I
supposed to do oh geez
there's gotta be a way to do this way
it's got to be a way to get to that
painting there by supplementing reality
enlightenment okay let's think about
this an eye over here on the ear over
there it means I should poke myself in
the eye and stab a knife in my ear yeah
I got it be right back everybody I am a
genius little girl little doll girl can
you can you help me out here I don't
know what I'm supposed to do
my brain is hurting my brain is gonna
explode at any minute now so I got four
balls of pee and there's a lady with an
umbrella you can stand under my umbrella
Allah there's gotta be something that
was being done with the gas over here
maybe now Gary can survive a bit longer
in the gas maybe maybe not I don't know
oh then ain't good
there was a nun Briella there but I
couldn't get through the gas so I didn't
know how that helped me Oh which one was
closer I don't know I hate being lost
oh I hate being lost
it only happens when I move glass I died
again
I died well this was rather inconvenient
towards my life sorry guys I'm just
being incredibly dumb and I don't know
what I'm supposed to do I'm trying to
think about this logically but I don't
know whether what other Avenue that I
can take there's a fishing hook here and
I know I probably send the umbrella up
isn't that what I do
hey hang on here oh I get it
Oh barely made that Gary's gonna die no
he's not I thought that was out of water
okay so yeah yeah there we go
that means that I can send the umbrella
over here say put the umbrella up there
and there we go okay for some reason I
thought that the gas wouldn't not let me
go forward and then okay all right I was
just being a big dumb there and that
means that I can go to the other side
now let me save first I can go to the
other side and that big okay I apologize
that was my fault that was bright in
front of my face still didn't see it
okay Fisher man hey look he be caught
something an umbrella Ilana
hey hey hey okay lady without her
umbrella give the umbrella take it lady
and now it's raining that doesn't help
wait why is that good thing uh whoa what
did that do what does that do for me oh
I know what it does it makes see all the
other thing at the other side I'm not
thinking correctly I'm thinking um in
very two-step areas cuz now
oh yeah baby oh yeah baby oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah
that's how we do it now we're making
progress now we're banging on all
cylinders now I've got this on lock I am
so smart and by smart I mean not smart
at all I once again saved in the wrong
spot
oh look heaps tears I bet we can take
them to the lower floor Atlas statue
statue in the way how about you push it
out the way aspiration how about I push
it down the stairs it's in the way push
down the stairs push it push gonna boys
it gonna push it what what oh come on
don't do this to me okay my aspiration
here my aspiration is to float on a moon
all a sleep-like and then have a swore
descend from the Stars and stab me in
the foot
it's the legend of the crazed mutt
stabber this is his origin some person
stabbed his whole family in the but then
he took vengeance on the world I'm done
like that somewhat but I still don't
know what I'm supposed to do still don't
know what I'm supposed to do
it's gotta be something here that I'm
missing doorknob is strangely cold what
is then I got a lighter I could light it
on fire could I use the lighter no okay
so there's gotta be something that I'm
missing but what is it I'm so close I'm
right on the tip of the tongue I thought
I was banging on all cylinders but
apparently not so that thing is in the
way then what are you gonna do about it
really Oh push it down the stairs what
no no no no no no no do not do that then
I know that button did that oh I'm stuck
again this whole episode has been
nothing but me constantly being stuck
over and over and over again
oh come on maybe there's a secret with
all these mannequins maybe one is not
like the others nope nope nope nope nope
nope they're all the same all of them
are the same there's still a few locked
doors and I don't know how to get into
them I'm just I'm just not I'm not
winning I'm not a winner right now
damnit what am I doing wrong there's
gotta be something here do something
about it Mary come on it's gotta be
something a missing there's gotta be
something on this I only need like two
more colors left until I got all the
colors of the palette I know that one is
in this room and one is like I've got to
be able to get away in here
use your lighter use your lighter I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I need three more colors oh
good golly I'm so far behind what
happened what was that oh really
suddenly that happens that's weird okay
but hey at least his progress that was
just like total happenstance ah here we
go
s page serpent spirit' I got a race I
really do have to write stuff down for
this game okay and here it six two four
eight okay abstract art don't need to
know about that then I need to know
about the age page hangman oh man six
two one nine two not an essence whatever
letter that was okay and then Mary which
has nothing I knew it I knew it girl
appears almost like lace naturally she's
not based on a real person
uh-huh I knew it I knew it
there's a familiar painting on the other
side of the page why it can't be that's
Mary I know he doesn't exist what does
that mean she's with it right now
Hiba
hello I don't need to look at any of
these some that ear was floating up and
down strain dear
what does that mean what's that I don't
know what that means but I'm worried
about Eve
I'm worried for Eva a disturbing doll I
picked up something good making it my
treasure what did you pick up stomach
looks bigger check the doll yep rip it
right open did that paint cuz I need it
suck on that little oh okay hey come
back here go okay never mind I'm gonna
go I am sorry I went in this room I
apologize I'm going to grab this paint
real quick and then go that's seven of
them okay
all right oh boy oh no oh no oh no oh no
let's have another treasure hunt
who who who has the key what is
oh no I didn't say it before this oh no
this is bad where's the key
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no whoa oh I have had enough of
that room why did I have to deal with
that because we're table ah made you
we've got to regroup soon indeed we do
that was really good I have to say
hahaha
it was actually really cool really well
done I think that's all the painting
pieces right yeah so now he should be
able to get the key
right well we're just gonna have to save
that for next time so anyway this game
is so cool I love the RVD war makers
that are really good like this I don't
know why I put this off so much ah so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
do not distort
Oh
Asia for that means
we got a little bit of
history going